foreign
runs into her ex-p Davidson you just
gotta roll with it rocks 50 000
freshwater pearls yeah Bible it's a
great look and suffers a wardrobe
malfunction at the 2023 Met Gala I don't
know what's gonna top that the reality
star looked stunning at Fashion's
biggest night on Monday in New York City
at the Metropolitan Museum of Art where
some of Hollywood's biggest stars
honored the late Chanel designer Carl
Lagerfeld this is Daniel for scaparelli
and um you know I wanted pearls I
thought what is more Carl you know the
iconic Chanel pearls is what I always
thought of so we wanted to just be
dripping in in pearls yeah those are
real pearls people yep last year Kim
made headlines for slipping into Marilyn
Monroe's happy birthday dress I tried it
on it didn't fit me and so I looked at
them and I said give me like three weeks
and I I had to lose 16 pounds down today
a to be able to fit this but I it was
such a challenge it was like a role
right I was just getting permanent yeah
I was determined to win it but this year
the skims founder said she just wanted
to have fun with her sisters Kendall and
Kylie Jenner who were also in attendance
I just wanted to have a good time I took
a shot before I came with my sisters my
daughter was in the room with me she's
actually in the car watching us you know
I'll walk up the red carpet so it was
just like a glamorous night yep Kim's
nine-year-old daughter Northwest flew to
New York with her famous mama and even
helped Kim out when the pearls on her
dress started to fall off on the way and
I told my daughter to grab them all
they're real pearls and she was putting
them all in her purse leading up to the
big night North surprised her mom with a
little pre-met pampering at the hotel oh
my gosh Carl Lagerfeld Met Gala
North
massages before the big day
how beautiful
and that sweet treat yourself moment
clearly worked because Kim was glowing
thank you but it wasn't just Kim's
fashion that had people talking Kim was
also snapped chatting with her ex Pete
Davidson inside the event that's Kim and
the Saturday Night Live Alum smiling ear
to ear having a convo with Usher it's
always so much fun of course last year
Kim and Pete attended the Met Gala
together
like so cute
yeah he's just super genuine and I love
the chemistry that Kim and him have
together it's really sweet I thought you
said the chemistry it's like okay
chemistry chemistry that could be a new
fragrance but the two called it quits in
August after nine months of dating and
now Pete is dating his bump kiss co-star
Chase Suey wonders but based on these
picks it looks like Kim and Pete are
totally friendly exes why not and the
most recent trailer for Hulu's the
Kardashians promises fans will get a
little more insight into Kim and Pete's
split when the show premieres May 25th I
don't even know where we left off we
were still in a relationship I was yep
damn
[Music]